[Music] L wins the drop but keeps the puck on
side that pass comes outside the line though
Flames have a chance short-handed here's Len on a
break scores ly Home Fires it home and the Flames
cut the lead to one second short-handed goal the
season for Calgary massive goal for the Calgary
Flames and I mean massive things don't look very
good you're in the Penalty Box bad pass D to D he
hits the official they get a bit of a break and
there goes Lyall a kick relief finally solved
Spencer Merton and you can see the torque in his
stick he got all of that one watch the stick oh
boy what a release and just like that the Flames
back in it on the road here with 923 to go first
period as mapani takes a look fires it down low
Sharon goich plays it over fed back to the line
Lyle Anderson with the shot off the outside of the
net Ma ponnie feeds it all the way back Far Side
weager Anderson hard pass lyol shoots scores lyol
what a start minute 16 seconds in Calgary makes
it one- nothing they're finally going to get
it back to Rasmus Anderson quickly ow to lyol
lyol was the last guy on the change uneven terms
again lyol to mapani nice play sharing goldage
stopped by Aon a rebound lyol scores lyol tucks
it under a two quick Balls by the Flames he fans
on this one completely and just drops the puck
right in the crease I said he has a good glove
hand well not that time and how about lyol I
mean he just stays with that rebound and just
tucks it right in all the way going to the net
and the puck gets behind and it just over the
line now Hanan he activates knocked Away by The
Stick of heroni we read that play well here's
Chris tanm now back to the point Sharon goic
a pass over to Lindholm he waits looks shoots
score Elias lindome has his Flames within
one it helps finally in this period Hanahan
defenseman is the one that jumps all the
way in to keep this Play Alive and when
he does so creates the offensive chance
and Sharon goich fakes the shot and what
a pass fools everybody and lyol patience
patience patience let it rip and cadri may
get credit for this goal as he goes to
net I'm not sure cadri says no but what
a play by lyol here no maybe not and that
is just under a minute to go in the third
period the Flames win the draw Rus Anderson one
timer from Han just as the net LOL [Applause]
scores and did it ever get
interesting 4 seconds left on the
clock what a break I mean off the boards right
on the tap for lyol after cadri wins the draw
straight back a shot from the point a favorable
bounce for the flames and they're still alive hits
Demco and then goes in the net off his P here's
a short hand a chance now for Anaheim Leon Works
to puck in with a shot and it goes off Anderson
around the boards right to Sharon govic takes off
the other way cadri passing to lyol shoots
scores lenol power play goal two nothing in
[Music] Calgary really nice job turning this
around and going the other way there's a shot
that goes wide now watch just how quickly they
enter the Zone get it to cadri he just Waits and
waits and waits sees lyol timing it perfectly
linol didn't enter the Zone too quickly and
make it easier to cover he just sort of hung back
waited for that opening and then beautiful shot
blocker side pass tipped Flames recovered
cadri L back to cadri now Hanford over to
cadri cadry S go to the front it's score
Leno tucks it in power play goal makes it
one [Applause] [Music] nothing and he gets one
here finally a good setup here by the Calgary
Flames they move it around and LOL with the first
good pass and then it comes right back to him and
gets a bit of a break and maybe that's what he
needed and the team needed as it goes right off
a skate off stori and then right back onto the
Stick of lyol and just like that after berserk